à 18 ans alison vote pour la première
fois elle espérait que son favori
mélenchon accèdent au second tour mais à
montceau les mines c'est bien le fn qui
passe en tête
un parti qu'elle rejette bassam eu un
côté un peu un peu raciste un peu enfin
peu beaucoup même ma foi bref il ya du
bon et du mauvais c'est pas étonnant que
les montcelliens ont dû être déçus je
pense la partie gauche et de droite donc
pas nous laisser les extrêmes ou tout
simplement
après faut voir faut voir si l'extrême
seront mieux que la gauche à droite
fossiles les électeurs du front national
ne sont pas faciles à trouver
hors caméra un jeune trentenaire jusqu'à
présent socialiste nous explique avoir
voté le pen pour la première fois par
colère dominique sans emploi a voté
aussi marine le pen je crois par
conviction et dans votre vie quotidienne
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui manque en
fait c'était ce que qu'est ce que
justement la vienne pourrait apporter
bas peut-être plus de
plus de travail aux gens qui en ont
besoin quoi et puis - dead à ceux qui
devraient moins en avoir c'est quand
même plus de gens qui ont besoin des des
pays qui n'en n'ont pas quoi plutôt les
régions du pays
ici à montceau-les-mines la population à
porter marine le pen en tête au premier
tour
à presque 27 % des voix une tendance que
l'on retrouve dans plusieurs communes
aux alentours du bassin minier
pourtant connu comme socialiste c'est le
cas de sanvignes les mines de saint
vallier ou encore de blanzy déjà aux
régionales en 2015 le front national
avait connu une forte poussée dans les
votes
la mer les républicains de
montceau-les-mines marie claude jarrot
explique ces chiffres par un vote de
souffrance et non pas d'adhésion
rappelons que le taux de chômage ici à
montceau-les-mines et de 17% s'apprête
de sept points de plus que la moyenne
nationale